freude herzlich willkommen zu einer
habe gestern abend das hähnchen in
gefällt uns perfekt zu machen ist aber
ist noch termine aber ich kann es
zusammen reißen weil es ist ja die habe
interessiert hat ja auch leid bin sehr
erst mal danke schön dass du mir das
macht es mit der jetzt noch daneben
geht das ganze in unser auch noch vor
man sieht was man da erlebt das ist auf
neuen folge eintrag persönlicher koch
von ganz verständlich bis hin zu bringen
verstehen frauen durchaus bewusst ist
gespannt also dass man eigentlich ein
die regel aufgestellt dass man hier noch
anfangen bei matter tomatensaft wollte
der kleineren schnellen snack für
sitzen zu müssen werden ist es jetzt
ist die schwänze brauchen wir jetzt
jeden fall alitalia es tatsächlich echt
hier in meiner küche zubereitet hat
butter milch eingelegt und das
ansonsten gekürzt wie gesagt gerne
und das ist ein absolutes highlight für
oder eine spur zufrieden aber
nicht so viel sagen darf aber war mir
zwischendurch ist im endeffekt ist ja
einfach so
weil du kannst natürlich gleich gerne
sieht so mächtig auf die tomate ist die
gefühl für sprache und jetzt an die
abchecken und sie uns vom nächsten video
kanzleramt ist halt einfach die haut
special spirito gesagt habe habe ich
nichtsdestotrotz dass ich das hier in
hätte nicht gedacht dass das in
mich denn heute bin ich der persönliche
einfach mal ein bisschen ein bisschen
folgendes ist wirklich von zeit aber man
vorbei so frische sachen sowie der der
nichts anderes wie ein käsebrot bisschen
auch probieren die repression machen was
deutschland überhaupt messe weil ich
wieder bis dahin geschafft
meiner eigenen wohnung in meiner eigenen
direkt so ein bisschen grob vom fett
comic machen jetzt keine keine
butterfahrt das szenario dass die einmal
kopf sondern heute ist ein echter
rührei drin sein wir haben also wirklich
handwerker der sich sich und seiner
wir sind recht ich bin wirklich sehr
hofer jetzt klebt das fleisch kam als
selbst hätte mir niemals und aufwand
auch immer aber wie sieht das erstmal
junge junge junge reflex ist dieses
frischen ja ein bisschen für die kruste
küche essen durfte bis hin zu nehmen von
befreit da ist immer so ein bisschen
persönlicher koch mein persönlicher koch
klassischen kommen ist ganz gerne bauen
partnerin was gönnen möchte bis hin zu
gab er wieder abbrechen weil es einfach
gemacht und es sieht erstmal wunderschön
fett und die bahn war künstlich und nach
zehn dankeschön dafür eine frage stellt
aus er wirklich diese verschiedenen
klebt so ein bisschen mehrere deswegen
alle komponenten ich habe bei der
sehr traurig aber sie schon die hoffnung
format das ist eine sache die mir grad
muss man das frittierte kartoffel halt
lucas er was neuer kommen gerne ins bild
die schere dass wir schön ganz raus
zubereitung zu gesehen sind einfach nur
farben chili haben wir dabei popcorn
oben noch mal so ein bisschen christen
aus also gebackenem ekicis und mit panke
oft als pommes bezeichnet wird gemacht
am horizont weil es gibt ja noch weitere
mir aber denn ich habe dir gesagt ich
schon verraten als porto einkauft was du
dem unternehmer der halt geschäftsessen
unfair dass warendorf macht die
mega super präzise gearbeitet und dafür
das hat mich sehr dass du da bist du
kriegen und dann noch ein bisschen was
drauf zu kriegen wäre ich habe jetzt
würde gerne überrascht werden zum
gerichte für mich kochen wird aber ich
haben wir dabei ich probiere man nur die
so ganz feine sticks die kleine
knoblauchbutter roma ist so ein paar
einkaufs und seinen kunden auch mega
noch mal oben drauf für den kranz wir
haben fürs auge parallel dazu gefangen
hast gesagt du wirst mich einen tag dann
abendessen ja was wird man in köln nicht
macht ich sehe dass der mittlerweile aus
hier noch geschmolzene butter hat ganz
kartoffel stift in diversen pflanzen ein
muss wirklich sagen das war was es mir
waffe
wichtig ja ich hoffe dass möglichst
dass wir zum ersten bully trolls mamma
haben eine intakte hommage ehre
bekommen es ist eine große ehre für mich
jetzt mal an unsere
oben jetzt einfach mit gleichen teilen
dem bett stall dabei wie wichtig es war
bisschen anbraten dass ich schön luftig
gewünscht habe und mehr so ich hab schon
essen kann es gibt schicken im ok oh ich
neue schienen angebracht das möglich ist
regional ist möglichst nachhaltig so gut
mia
und haben es mir leicht gemacht nein
sind noch mal so ein bisschen das
obendrauf noch mal in butter geschwenkt
sind und arm und zero platt und damit
mutter die
ich habe mich die ganze zeit darüber
brecko spiritus gegessen auch selbst
kataster zu geben ich stelle mich die
das haben wir unsere kenntnisse sein
also auch mal so ja ich sagen wirklich
wurde ich bis dahin nicht produzieren
wie es geht locker nicht so wirklich
schon mal eine geile so sowie wir
nach dass ihn einfach nur essen will und
liebe schöne worte das war auf jeden
kann dann rissen wir unseren pankofen
schon gemacht ich find's übels lecker
das gericht da kannst du fast gar nicht
ganze zeit hier mehr so in bewunderung
sagen ich bin ganz ehrlich kollegen das
nachher schön über zu schicken aber
wurde dabei waren also du kommst in den
betriebe würfel in die butter und
drei rezepte frühstück mittag abendessen
aus mit dem rührei ingrid das
jetzt kann ich endlich habe ich mal
fall vor meinen geschmack getroffen wir
aber
das ist ja genau das ist meine ich muss
und
bio siegel wir haben wenn ich weiß wo es
was von alle mitnehmen weiß so
probiert zwischen für sich selbst
teufeln können bacon ist knusprig fahne
krieg jeden haben eben etwas anderes was
schnitten die ganzen kleinen prise salz
sind so richtig amerikanisch hättest du
funktioniert so gut aber du hast durch
rund alles ist sich konnte ich meine man
vielschichtig ist ein bisschen von
herkommt und rat bei tieren wie die
alles ganz klassisch oder dass ich die
parallel dazu können wir eigentlich
andere herd du hast andere gema ist es
wirklich sagen einiges an potenzial was
und das ganze wenn wir gleich mit mir
gesagt wir waren in den ersten zwei
chicken selbst eine ecke von der waffe
es noch schön warm und vor allem auch
die gewürze und einfach die kleinen step
zuschauer hoffentlich etwas lernen kann
tiere gelebt haben ist es mir wichtiger
schon mal unseren käse langsam in die
merkte ich das drauf hast kann es gar
dinger neben wieso im street food
ein bisschen welchen fett drin weil wir
also man quasi eine klassische
nicht perfekt laufen könnte weil du hast
mit dem kozlov finde das auch jetzt
weil du machst das was ich mir
ist jeden tag anders und dann sind so
wie jeden siegel wie lange hast du das
soße hier aber in diesen basis
sie gemacht was hast du so diesen
bereich rest kommt dann bleiben wir
darüber gesprochen haben das sollte noch
nicht abwarten zu essen immer ein
mehlschwitze löschen das mit dem stuck
eigentlich überlegt habe einen tag leute
konstant wie zum beispiel das eigene
authentischen geschmack zu mir in die
die nudeln die du in eine auflaufform
ganze schon als persönlicher koch das
dabei nicht dass ich wüsste dass machen
einbringen auch hier ist mehr wieder
bisschen pflanzen heiß gemacht warten
beinahe punkt noch ein bisschen sah noch
gar nicht haben noch ein bisschen butter
schon geil das alles auf einem teller
scheibe messer
gar ziehst du hast das erste total
private chef und wie kommt es vertretbar
küche gebracht so und das finde ich
können sich immer verlassen kann man ja
ist kontrolliere
jetzt einfach um die politik
mehr
nicht dazu dass ganze gucken wir dann
zum frühstück gibt es bringt fast
endstufe also das ist muss ich natürlich
zerbrechlich eigentlich dass homer
letzten jahres fahrzeug nicht man darf
etwa veh dann ich erwarte perfektion
ein schuss den käse unter dass wir da
mühelos ganz genau ich meine ich habe
das ganze schön dass ich anderen der
es kaum glauben eine der positiven
fleisch welches da auch mit drin ist
jetzt hab ich auch gekauft
auch wieder bewerten von 0 bis 10 aber
wir sehen uns gleich
überlegt wenn ich die gelegenheit habe
geschichten es gibt ja ich war zum
deshalb bin ich gespannt so die gal
ich stehe die ganze zeit rum so ich koks
die bindung kriegen dann ist auch schon
der automatischen gewürfelt dann rote
ich hab's ja gerade schon gesagt was ich
punkte jeweils getroffen sind aber von
wir haben gemeinsam heute parallel hat
und lukas haben wird super gut kochen
letzten zeitpunkt in der anstellung hat
fast zu weit dann geht es los
termin der wirklich schöne kenne ich
starten einfach direkt mit dem fit mit
und mit einem auge zu aber ich kann
wollte und mehr als kann nun zehn sein
gut kummer aber eins das sich lohnt also
der anrichten können das auch wieder ein
zwiebel ein bisschen peperoni knoblauch
juni so sieht das ganze aus und fertig
keinen chef habe in einem 4 sterne
heute ja eigentlich einfach schön würden
wir das richtig drauf hat was wünsche
bestimmt da kommen gleich den kopf nein
so es war einfach nur köstlich und das
buttermilch anstatt normaler mich und
uhr übrigen bisschen creme fraiche ann
punkt mehr du bringst teller mit ja das
langsam beim abendessen merke ich dann
wellnesshotel füße geschmissen und habe
ich mir ganz einfach sachen die man
und koriander stile wochen mit dazu dann
das
kathrin und das war's - was
wirklich diese kreation ich habe erst
ich musste mir drin dann kommen dann
wirklich könnte ich jeden tag
auch wenn ich jetzt dann auf dem balkon
ist eine art des games teller besteck
eigentlich nicht bekommt bleibt ritus
dann gesagt du kannst nicht kochen alle
hast du auch selber mitgebracht genau
frühstücken weise dass gesundes ist
als erstes ist ausgelöst also dass keine
gedacht wow da ist ein bisschen viel was
habe ich uns auch zwei servietten das
sucht man vergebens hier in köln ich
haben wir etwas
sie hätten gehört ist halt klassisch
länder dazu alle restaurants dazu ein
ausgewogen ist einfach nur lecker
süßes brauner zucker brauner zucker kann
liebe sie aber deshalb macht eine magie
abgeht auf dem teller wir haben denken
ich bringe viele sachen also gewürze öle
gehört dazu und es macht auch viel aus
knüppel mir dran kein knochen mehr drin
wäre mir unsere unsere soße unsere
außer haus geschäft in dem hotel zu
mexikanische küche es ist halt scharf
ich stelle mich schon ein bisschen und
wir haben technisch hinnehmen wir haben
essige
eine kante hat auch mit knochen machen
wird nicht weniger besonders beim
also dadurch dass man so quasi die farbe
so verfügen jetzt zu einem schönen
etablieren wo die leute haben wollen den
macarons die sind nicht ganz alle
aber ich finde gerade für das gericht
man ist so machten die tomaten gewürzt
was hast du überlegt welche zutaten ab
hauptkorn wir haben waffen mit
glatten teig
hintern und welches zimmer hat es war
sauer so und das bringt hat noch mal
schicken hoffe das ist halt ohne knochen
überhaupt die sagen wenn man jetzt über
der humanitäre nochmals das so allein zu
mittagessen es gibt eine sache die wir
sofort mitgebracht ich habe mich fangen
schwierig ja dann habe ich die sache
richtig richtig kraft in die creme
meersalz
krautsalat so viele komponenten ich
viel viel besser ob man es halt einfach
den packungen davon ausgeht dass man die
hause so was haben zu können ist schon
in miami gegessen haben nämlich lobster
etwas auch in der heimischen produziert
wir vorne an ich habe eine kleine kunde
ist es dann zu reden einmal durch lassen
essen kann ohne dass man sich um den
fraiche scheint mir noch dass speck
wo ich einige kurzer kochen kann weil
in den teig grafen den städten nicht
besonders genug zum zur anrichte genug
dachte klar ist sieht super aus aber die
mcinnis und das kann noch krasser
wirft tomate mitgebracht wurden schöne
ist auf eine weitere person im haushalt
stehen und mich sein zu können den
knochen kümmern musst das machen jetzt
verfange da kommt ja noch dazu da geht
jetzt einmal nutzen hin richtig machen
erste gase wo alles drauf was da so gut
tomaten zu machen ein bisschen in der
kommen ja ob die jetzt essen betrifft
mit einstecken und dann sehen wir uns
zum aussehen ich gehe erst mal in die
gewürzen tomaten ein bisschen wasser
essbaren schmilzt ja direkt und dann
bildhübsche zutaten für unsere
gleich beim checken wir unsere waffe war
frühlings züge für den knapp wir machen
nur migranten nehmen ab und dann bin ich
dass wirklich alles gehört zusammen
einfach immer waren regional- und dann
direkt wieder so eine premiere das ist
die hochzeit jetzt geheiratet jetzt
mccanns rein
mittagessen wir haben drei verschiedene
ein geiles rührei aber mit nazi statt
alles passt zu seinem unfassbar lecker
das hier lesen du hast diese käse posten
geht es auch schon nachrichten ein
halt die eine person ja zufällig habe
das geilste käsebrötchen der käse hat ja
seite und machen gleich noch einmal
sorten käse pizza oder in pankow
kommt aber jetzt kommt auch der
waren mit dem rhein zusammen wichtig ist
sinnbildlich für den tag heute wirklich
ich essen dabei und auch beruflich
milch und sahne tod elias ein bisschen
okay er ist beeindruckt sich auch sehr
es war ja ja neben dem brötchen gebacken
soundtrack mit einer sonder bisschen
wie eben das feld auch weil darin
selbständig jetzt damit seit
wichtig keine farbe vor allem wegen ein
einfach nur kraft also alles darauf auch
ist und dass so ein bisschen idee hinter
bisschen kraut habe kerviel das ist ja
bratensatz für ein bisschen mehr ist
programms und der star der show
schön aus natürlich noch ganz ist hart
mitte letzten jahres für mitte letzten
super zubereitet deshalb noch mal
creme fraiche wir machen bog ab ohne ein
mal ganz gut generell zu suchen hast du
bisschen krautsalat drauf wir haben dann
automatischer hunger sondern auch gut
dem chat kann dafür sorgen dass auch
herzlichen dank und ich muss wirklich
mehr kraft ins rheinland gewann schnell
sagen das ist eine dicke zehn von zehn
schicken das ist jetzt doppelt
bisschen rote zwiebel koriander dann
käse zu dieser tradition steht jetzt
jahres hast du angefangen mit dem herzen
ist kann noch werden also wie gesagt man
schon irgendwie muss man aber nicht kein
okay okay würde sagen wir sehen uns
an die bürger dann immer noch ein
spaß wie viele kunden dort leben
machen wir quasi ganz feine pumps wieder
ist so ne 10 von 10 dass ich nicht weiß
dann erst unsere soße
habe mir das gegessen lausanne entschied
bisschen parat wenn sie schneidet man
vielleicht wieder natürlich teller liegt
gang eingelegt hat sie mal ganz
auch frühstück oder das besser weil ich
bekommen kann man gut durch die c- bis
die die kerne raus sehr scharf und sagen
noch einmal zu finden für den clubman
das ganze etwas ganz besonderes und auch
klassischen geräuchert und da war man
jetzt knapp 100.000 gäste die sich quasi
war wirklich sagt eigentlich schon und
wie sollte es anders sein ein bisschen
gefühlt schöner dann dürfen wir einfach
schon ein tor salatic
ist auch ich sage ehrlich das pixon sehr
muss man auch sagen was ganz dekadent
ist noch da und ich bin auch sehr froh
ein bisschen chili für die schärfe
ich hab das vergessen und ich habe sie
zu hause in den eigenen vier wänden
verein und dann kommen noch ein bisschen
darüber ablegen
verpasst weil ich mir dachte überhaupt
ist auf diesem weg entschied mit dem
geprobt hat glaube das spricht dafür
knusprigen das bringe hühnerhaut und
so das ist so lecker und ich kenne es
dass auf jeden fall auch gut schmeckt
hunger zusammen zugute das ist wirklich
verkraften ist unbedingt auf instagram
sehr gut habe ich auf jeden fall noch
die mittel dazu also wir halten die
noch nicht wechseln musste das mitnehmen
da kommt jetzt ich glaube dass das
eine besondere sache die man nirgendwo
und auch geht einfach und tatsächlich
obendrauf karamell broadcom ich habe
vorbeischauen ihr werdet auch im verlauf
vorkammer fertig wo generell etwas
mal was man davon zu essen feedback was
und ich danke dir
100.000 gäste in einem jahr also was das
krieg sondern lukas weis ich zu hause
geilste kombinieren produkt der welt die
hier unfassbar gut gelungen ist besser
des videos lukas kann richtig gut kochen
wasser sagte ich hoffe nur gutes was
ich hoffe dass auch ein bisschen spaß
natürlich thomas halter da ist auch
und ich übergebe dann starten direkt mit
noch als ich es in miami hatte ist wie
gute alte karimi
also richtig gut deshalb freue ich mich
für ein aufwand ist man ich kenne ja
und ich hatte es nicht nur arbeitet
schon ein bisschen schärfen mit drin
barbecue rapp aber halt mit
dem handy die hommage winter und die
ansatzweise ihr die sachen die du machst
hast du mir drin haben auch noch einen
du den hunger geschmack war sie
heute kann man auf jeden fall spaß
unseren wert und für zuhause materien
selleriesalat ist ein bisschen dieses
hervorgehoben hast kerbel war das kraut
schere das ganze nicht mehr auseinander
gemacht definitiv in kohlscheid
thema co2 wieder aufgreift und das ganze
eine neue küche gehen sich einfinden
monat nach dem ko ko gewürzt mit sesam
unbedingt bei einem kurs vorbei du bist
nehmen wir eigentlich nur
hast du sowieso gerne ich habe vor
ja das hat irgendwie das ist
einkaufen alles mitbringt alles portabel
durch so ein bisschen die
auch cherrytomaten hatte ich noch mal um
nicht mehr ausgebucht für diese serie
meinem haus und hof wenn es gar ein
verschmolzen du hast deftige mcinnis
zwischenschicht zwischen dieser cremig
total frisch deswegen hängt er wie
bisschen frühstück wegen mitgemacht
zunächst in der eigenen gewürze deine
geboten dafür gibt's noch nächstes jahr
halten wird und das ist ja philipp hatte
waffe und dem fluss bringen hähnchen
erwartet und du hattest auch so eine
mitgebracht hat er ist eingelegt fahren
teufel hinten ich glaube dass jetzt ein
eigenen meine eigenen ich wollte jetzt
was ich war ich bin wirklich fasziniert
also ein geiler krautsalat wir haben ich
kräftig kite aber trotzdem so eine süße
das ist nicht der der klassische weg den
noch maria und ich dachte gerade auch
das ist mega trudchen in doppelter natur
und klären den hunger hat in gar keiner
man sonst eher so eine gewisse unruhe
herum und der islamischen gab ist ein
die wahrscheinlich auch wahnsinnige
art und bald in den schatten gestellt
schon lukas hier die ganze zeit mit
text der klassische abspecken kann man
ich fand die nudeln waren etwas drüber
story da gibt es einiges was man daraus
denen mit dem gewürzmischung aber es
dadurch dass sie halt 30 minuten im
sind seine gewürze also wer sich dafür
backofen mitgekocht sind ich würde dir
schwenke zwischen zwei noten neun von
zehn gewicht also es ist trotzdem
wahnsinnig gut aber das nicht hat
[Musik]